-Oh, we love you.
It's so good to see you.
-It's so good to see you
in person.
-In person.
Yeah, last time, it was Zoom.
It was Zoom.
-I know. I know.
-I'm so happy you're here.
You look great.
-Thank you.
I'm happy to be here.
-We have a lot of --
We have a lot to talk about.
You're very --
-It's gonna be a long interview.
-Yes, it's gonna be
a 45-minute interview.
[ Laughter ]
You are -- You're in the middle
of shooting season five...
-Yes.
-...of "The Handmaid's Tale."
Season four, by the way,
you ended with a banger.
-Oh, yes.
A bit of a bang, yes.
-It was wild.
It was wild.
-It was a lot.
-Yeah, you didn't really
warn me for that.
-Sorry about that.
-Yeah, it was --
-I should have texted you.
-Yeah, can you say
what this five --
season five is gonna be?
Is it gonna be a --
-We figured the physical comedy
was really working for us.
-Yeah, that's
what it's known for.
Yeah, "The Handmaid's Tale."
-The prat -- the pratfalls.
-Yeah, pratfalls.
-So there's just more of that.
-Spit takes.
-More spit takes.
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
-We're just gonna up the fun.
-Up the comedy.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's --
-It's working.
You will all like it, right?
-Yes, people think --
-What people love about
"The Handmaid's Tale."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is not gonna happen
at all.
You're directing more episodes
this season.
-Yeah.
-And you were telling me
that you have someone
shadowing you.
-Yes.
So I'm directing three episodes
this year, and I have --
When someone shadows you,
they literally shadow you.
They follow you around,
and they --
-To learn the ropes.
-To learn the ropes
and learn the show.
I have a young, up-and-coming
actor named Bradley Whitford
shadowing me.
[ Laughter ]
Very sweet.
I wish him well in his career.
-Oh, yeah.
-One day, yeah.
-You think he's gonna make it?
-One day.
-Yeah, exactly.
-He'll keep at it.
He'll keep at it.
-So he's -- Bradley Whitford.
-Yes. We wanted to welcome him
to the office.
And we wanted to welcome him
in the style
that we felt that he deserved.
-So you put it --
-And so --
-You made him his own desk.
You gave him his own desk.
-Yes.
-Right outside the office.
It's a little --
It's a child's desk.
That's him there.
[ Laughter ]
Can we zoom in?
He's got crayons.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-See?
Look.
-He spelled his name right.
-He's got a nice sign.
He can make --
He can make notes and drawings.
-Construction paper
and everything, yeah.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty funny, man.
Is he -- Will you give him
our best, please?
-I absolutely will.
I adore that man.
-I want to talk about your new
show, "The Shining Girls."
This is based off of a book
of the same name.
Can you set up that show?
-Yes, I will do my best.
So, it is about
a woman named Kirby
who works at the
"Chicago Sun-Times."
And she --
The show picks up
six years after she has survived
a brutal assault.
And there is another murder
that happens in Chicago.
The show is set in '92.
And she starts to investigate
that murder because of
the similarities between that
and her own assault.
Now, that said, there's also
this whole other element
to the show
that she's dealing with this
ever-changing reality
that's happening in her life.
Like, literally,
things change around her.
So she has to figure out
why and how that's happening.
And maybe the two things
are connected.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
But you -- you --
That was a very good
explanation.
You act in it.
You produced it.
You even directed
a few episodes of this.
Hey, what is going on with you?
[ Laughter ]
You are so talented.
You 're just doing it all.
-Glutton for punishment.
[ Laughs ]
-I mean, it's hard enough to --
Don't you think
it's hard enough to act?
-It is --
It is hard enough to act,
especially the kind of work
that I -- that I do.
And, you know,
it is getting easier.
I will say, the directing
and acting is so hard
and takes up so much
of your mind
that now when
I'm just directing
or I'm just acting, I'm like,
"Oh, my God, this is so easy."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah. Right.
I mean, come on.
-So when I'm acting, I'm like --
-You're Elisabeth Moss,
so you're allowed to say that.
Yeah, of course.
But I mean, do you ever
screw up a scene acting,
and you're acting,
and you mess up, and you're
like, "Sorry, everybody,"
and then you're mad at yourself?
-How dare you suggest I mess up.
-No, never!
Of course not!
No, no, no. Never!
You would never --
-How dare you.
-No, you wouldn't --
"How dare you!"
-Insulting!
[ Laughter ]
-"I've never been
more insulted in my life!"
-I mess up all the time,
but it -- it's great,
'cause you get to go again.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, you're like,
"Hey, that's just the --
that's the way it is."
-Yeah, it's not theater.
-"Except for you, by the way.
You gotta remember your lines."
Yeah, but everyone else
is allowed to make mistakes.
-Absolutely.
-I know that the story
takes place in Chicago.
-Yeah.
-And you filmed it in Chicago.
We got to film in Chicago.
My mom's from Chicago.
-I know you're a Cubs fan.
-Yeah.
-You -- yeah.
So that was good.
I wanted to ask you a question,
because you go to the Cubs game.
You order a hot dog.
What do you get on your hot dog?
You get...
-[ Sighs ] Ketchup,
which is very controversial.
I know.
-Wrong answer.
-I know it's the wrong answer.
[ Cheering ]
-It's the wrong an--
-Well, thank you!
-No!
-Thank you!
-Let's vote on it!
-Yes, ketchup!
-Let's vote -- let's vote on it!
No, no, no.
We're not going to vote.
We don't have
the clickers anymore.
They are ready
for the ketchup vote.
-Yeah, they're ready
-We have the ketchup cue.
-There was a viral video
over the weekend.
Some people
thought it was gross.
I don't know
what to feel about it.
But it was a Yankee fans
had a very unusual way
of eating a hot dog.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
[ Audience groaning ]
-Okay.
What is weird about that?
[ Laughter ]
What do you think happens
in your stomach?
-No!
But you don't start there.
-It's all gonna come together.
-You start here, you end there.
We don't even end there,
but anyway.
-I do not think
it's that weird.
-Well, let's see
how weird it is.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Damn it.
-What do you think?
I got -- all right.
I put a little mustard
on my jam.
But this is gonna be --
-Do I get ketchup?
Oh, awesome.
-You got ketchup on yours, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Cheers.
-Okay, cheers!
-Nice to see ya, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get it in there.
Get it in there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No.
♪♪
-No.
-No, thumbs down.
-It ruined everything.
-Thumbs down.
That guy's insane.
-It ruined everything.
Everything I thought
it would be.
-Don't do that.
-It ruined everything.
Ruined the beer.
-Do not do it.
-It tastes like
an old, cold hot dog.
-Soggy.
-It reminds you of the ballpark.
I will say, I admit...
[ Laughter ]
Now it, kind of, took me back
to the baseball game.
-Separate's fine.
Not together.
-Not together, no.
-No, ketchup or mustard.
Don't do it together.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Elisabeth Moss
in "Shining Girls."
Take a look at this.
-Look these over
and see if something clicks.
What about these?
Really look.
Kirby.
-I don't know,
because I don't know
what he looks like.
Okay?
He could be the guy at A&P
bagging my milk.
He could be the creep behind me.
He could be the...
holding up the door.
He's everybody.
He's nobody.
He's all the...time.
-Aw, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Elisabeth Moss!
"Shining Girls" premieres
on Apple TV+ this Friday.